[Musique]
le 19
bars et restaurants
la cité l'intérieur des établissements
devra attendre le 9 juin pour accueillir
de nouveau des clients avec des tables
et de six personnes au maximum
ils sont très forts ils ont réussi à
inventer la jauge en terrasse la jauge
en extérieur là où la contamination
n'existe pas où elle est quasiment nul
et son magnifique on se dit on a touché
le fond cette fois ils ne feront pas
mieux mais non les petits hommes gris
avant de détruire auquel personne
n'avait pensé à ce à quoi je pense je
pense à la phrase de pegi pegi dit ce
que l'on voit mais plus difficile il
faut voir ce que l'on voit c'est pas
d'afflelou zh en revanche très bonne
nouvelle
le premier ministre a annoncé la
réouverture des remontées mécaniques le
30 juin je trouve que le confinement de
déconfinement est un peu tôt me
semble-t-il
on est encore plus contaminée qu'il ya
six mois
macron une phrase génial dadis et ses
ratés mais c'est un échec donc il fait
ça dans un film où l'on s'amuse c'est
que les jauges entérale j'ai regardé
quand même un dans le monde entier
vous entendez bien personne c'est j'ai
regardé angleterre ça existe nulle part
les jauges en terrasse
blague cmec jeu non plus
moi je suis d'accord ce principe de
rêverie la culture c'est permettent aux
gens de réfléchir et d'accéder un peu
eux mêmes donc c'est la base de tout on
a été privé de sa pendant six mois
maintenant les chiffres sont les
chiffres
objectivement et encore 5000 personnes
en réanimation moi je trouve c'est
beaucoup trop volage et les copains qui
auront le courage de continuer leurs
études
qimni fais gaffe c'est pas impossible
que ça à faire donc je suis plutôt
dubitatif voilà je suis content comme
français préconisé oui c'est l'académie
k'bidi faut dire la cobi d'alors
quelques snobinard n'est ce pas les
yamaha s'était mis à dire la coved son
sol abriter le petit robert estime que
celle usage qui fait loi
en clair une majorité de français dit le
co vide donc coville est un nom masculin
dans le dictionnaire flat franchement
l'année ce qui n'a ni tes plats bernard
sabbah nous avons l'explication hier
soir c'est vrai que ça s'est très très
mal passé avec votre épouse lorsque vous
avez vous vu dans l'intimité
j'ai offrir un bon moment et elle a je
crois ou un conseil à vous donner
et c'est les haricots voilà alors c'est
beaucoup c'est une question
d'alimentation en fait bernard ouais ça
va mais je suis en train de faire ma
poêlée de légumes les légumes et je les
mets dans quel sens je mets quoi la
toute fin pour assaisonner
promis si je gagne je t'invite au resto
d'accord donc déjà mais toi dans la tête
que c'est toi qui va payer
à moins de dix mois aux indices tarifs
et antonio le chercher dans le gâteau du
gag
sortez dehors des grosses grosses ces
bosses caf
c'est bon t'es prêt à laisser partir
les assez court et dense c'est pas grave
il bosse qui les lie
il va courir et pascale ancienne pascal
el-assad et la voilà on est alors en
retard qu'est-ce qu'il a atteint la
première fois je dois voter c'est entre
chirac et mitterrand y en avait un qui
était premier ministre quand j'étais à
l'école primaire sympa c'est un
dinosaure qui finale et il y en avait un
qui était mise justice et d'intérieur
comme mon père était appelé en algérie
il m'a dit ce matin est au courant de ce
qui se passait et il n'a rien fait
niamey 50 condamnation à mort
tant qu'il est au pouvoir il aurait pu
gracié donc j'avais une méfiance assez
légitime par rapport à ces personnages
aux ego disproportionnée assez fascinant
d'ailleurs et ça me fout les jetons donc
dans le doute je m'attends souvent
premier vote oui mais c'est en quatre
reprises abete
c'était mon premier mac os et démontre
au niveau du grand village
beaucoup de gens se prenaient en photo
et on n'a toujours pas compris pourquoi
avec un doigt dans le nez de trump donc
on a dû beaucoup refaire le nez on
essaye que nos visiteurs respecte la
plupart des personnages chacun vote et
nettoyer ma plastique c'est ce que je
fais déjà tous les jours sur noir donc
nettoyé des bouteilles d'eau ya aucun
problème je sais très bien comment ça
fonctionne
dès qu'on a retirés donald trump on a eu
énormément de demandes pour acquérir
alors pas seulement la tête l'ensemble
du personnage
donc c'est des fans qui connaissent
parfois un peu virulent de même
certaines personnes se sont débrouillés
pour avoir
mon adresse et mon numéro de téléphone
personnel la plupart c'était des
acheteurs en france et 5 étonnant mais
j'ai aussi un appel d'angleterre et les
personnages sont pas à vendre
exceptionnellement donald trump pourrait
récupérer son personnage qui nous
contactent
auteur
pitié 500 euros et quand ce n'est pas
ses bras
quand on
une plongée dans le lac baïkal en russie
pour un phénomène étrange des aiguilles
de glace se sont formés à la surface du
lac le plus profond du monde avancé à la
nage n'est pas évident pour ce plongeur
l'explication elle n'est pas simple mais
seppi qui glace et serait due à un
changement de saison trop brutale dans
ce coin de sibérie formons ce paysage
étonnant fans ont fait danser a pris
pour qu'il pleuve se réunit pour qu'il
pleuve pour qu'il pleuve
nous on est des anciens peut sceller 2.0
mais il croise qui vont plus vite que
l'ordinateur
il croit et croit éric ruf sinistre vous
préparez et vous faire beau grâce albert
gosse et vous occupez de rien je
s'occupe de tout romano cry koudou be
love one love by à 40 ans le chanteur de
reggae bob marley nous qui te c'était le
11 mai 1981 à l a fait connaître le
reggae la musique jamaïcaine dans le
monde entier bob marley qui inspire tous
vos quarante ans après sa mort